The year is 1933, and the world around us
is changing, for better and for worse.
King Kong amazes movie audiences.
The 21st Amendment ends Prohibition.
And around the corner looms a dark period
for the world.
Amidst this backdrop, scientists continue
to fill the world with wonders, conceiving
of astronomical marvels and medical miracles.
And as they dive deeper into the invisible
world around us, a rare ciliate makes an appearance….
And after an absence of almost 90 years, we’ve
found it again.
We aren’t in the business of news here at
Journey to the Microcosmos.
But we do sometimes find something that feels
like it should be breaking news.
Like when James, our master of microscopes,
manages to find a microbe that hasn’t been
spotted since the 1930s—
that always gets the rest of us on the Journey
to the Microcosmos team excited because we
know we’re about to see something weird.
And ‘weird’ is exactly what James brought us.
The organism that he found is that oval-ish
character with a twisted tail at one end.
And that tail ended up making it really difficult
for James to get other scientists to believe
what he had found.
But before we get there, let’s start with
how James managed to find this microbe to
begin with, which really leads us
to a question that you might not think
about when you’re walking around:
how old is that pond?
Now obviously the answer depends
on which pond you’re talking about.
If you live in a city like James does, the
ponds you stumble across are much more likely
to be on the younger side.
And that poses a bit of a conundrum for James
in his hunt for his particular microbial specialty:
ciliates.
Because when it comes to finding hotspots
of ciliate diversity, older ponds are much better.
Ciliates can spread to new locations as cysts,
which get carried by the wind or animals from
one spot to another.
So a pond that has been around for a while
will probably have welcomed many new residents
over the years, building a diverse microscopic
neighborhood in the process.
There is this one particular lake in Warsaw,
though, that's been a curiously rich spot
for ciliates, which was surprising to James
given how young ponds usually are in cities.
But when he looked through older maps of Warsaw,
he found that this pond had been around for
at least 130 years, and probably even longer,
giving it plenty of time to accumulate more
and more ciliates, including rare ones.
When James found this organism four years
ago, he was so excited to have uncovered what
he was sure was a member of the genus Bryophyllum.
He’d found so many of them in this pond, and he
wanted to be able to learn more from an expert.
So he reached out to someone who works on
this genus, sending an email that included
images of what he had found and mentioned
just how many of them he’d found.
But when he heard back, the expert simply
told him that the ciliate he’d found was damaged—
that the weird tail wasn’t actually a tail, it was
just something wrong with the sample he collected.
And that response was discouraging, especially
given how many other individuals like this
James had found.
But our Master of Microscopes
is nothing if not persistent,
so he returned to the pond.
And on his way, he posted about his hunt for
a rare ciliate on Instagram.
And then he got a response from the ciliate expert
Professor Genoveva Esteban, who has since
become one of James’ main collaborators.
Though at the time, they were just acquaintances.
Professor Esteban asked James what he was
on the hunt for, and he sent her the picture
of the tailed ciliate, it blew her mind.
She had never seen anything like it in her
long years of exploring the microcosmos, but
she was able to uncover a German paper from
1933 by a Professor J. V. Gelei.
And when James looked through the illustrations
in the paper, he found his tailed ciliate.
It wasn’t damaged at all—
it was just so rare that the last report of
one went back decades.
It was tricky, but James was able to identify
the species as Bryophyllum caudatum by looking
at specific patterns where the cilia roots
into the plasma membrane.
These patterns are really hard to see with
a light microscope, James was just able
to make out those identifying details with
his.
It was frustrating though to try and convince
others of what he’d found.
Even though he kept his samples in a large
tank and kept turning up more tailed Bryophyllum,
one of the scientists he talked to insisted
that there was no actual tail.
That what he was seeing was maybe some
kind of remnant of how he pipetted his samples
onto the slide—
that James was stretching and deforming the
cell into forming a tail-like structure.
James just rolled his eyes and made a handheld
microscope to watch the Bryophyllum in action
in the tank.
And there he could see several of them swimming
around on the sediment, their tails very much
present without James’ intervention.
And that means the Bryophyllum he
found were not damaged—
they were just a perfect combination of
weird and rare that does make them hard to believe.
Tails are not a common trait among ciliates.
And even more strangely, James found that
the length of the tail seemed to vary from
individual to individual.
Given how rare Bryophyllum are, it’s hard to
establish exactly what the purpose of their tail is.
But James has a few ideas.
One is that the tail might be
involved in helping the organism
survive in low-oxygen areas, increasing the
Bryophyllum’s surface area so that they
can take in more oxygen.
So individuals that live in areas with lower
oxygen concentrations would have a longer tail.
But the tail might also help Bryophyllum eat,
because it’s lined with extrusomes, which
are organelles that can be fired off to paralyze
food.
In this case, we can see the Bryophyllum paralyzing
rotifers and turning them into food.
And here is a well-fed Bryophyllum, stuffed
with rotifers.
When James was telling us about his experience
with the Bryophyllum caudatum, the thing that
stood out to him most was how challenging
it was to convince people of its existence,
and how formative Professor Esteban’s belief
in what he’d found was.
She didn’t discourage him.
Instead she hunted, digging through old texts
with the same persistence that James shows
with old city ponds.
Unfortunately, despite years of encounters,
the Bryophyllum seem to have disappeared from
the pond.
But who knows, maybe they’ll turn up
there again, or in some distant pond.
And when someone finds it and isn’t sure
of what they found, we hope they can at least
find this video—
a letter from a past microscopist who believes
in them.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
Given the fact that you just watched this
entire video, we’re going to go ahead and
assume that you enjoy learning on YouTube.
Well, did you know that you can actually earn
college credit for doing that?
You see, the company that produces Journey
To The Microcosmos also produces a lot of
other shows, and one of those shows is Study
Hall, a channel that lets you start taking
college courses right here on YouTube!
Here’s how it works:
You watch the course videos on the Study Hall
channel for free, and then sign up for an online
college course led by ASU faculty for just
$25 and apply what you have learned.
If at the end of the course you’re happy
with your grade, pay $400
(which is about a third of
the cost of a college credit!)
and now you have 3 transferable college credits
on your transcript!
Whether you’re trying to learn new skills,
earn college credit, or just prove to yourself
that you can do it, Study Hall may help you
reach your goals without the financial risk!
You can pick between common gen-ed college courses
like Modern World History, Human Communication,
and more on the Study Hall channel!
Check out GoStudyHall.com or click the link
in the description to learn more.
The names on the screen right now, those are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who make it possible for
us to continue on this journey.
Just think of this.
When you first heard that a ciliate had been
found that hadn't been seen in 90 years, did
you think that it was our Master of Microscopes
who would have found it?
I bet you didn't.
But it was and that's one of the reasons I
think what we do here is pretty special.
If you want to help us out, you can go to
Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.